so how does it work and crucially how do
you win
well the national vote doesn't determine
who sits in the white house
each state is allocated a set number of
electors
based partly on its population called
the electoral college
there are 538 in total so the candidate
that gets the support of at least
270 electors becomes president
this was a picture in 2016 when hillary
clinton
lost to donald trump after receiving 227
votes
to his 304. she lost the electoral
college but she won the popular vote
receiving almost 3 million more votes
nationally
than donald trump ultimately
presidential elections are decided by
swing states shown here in gold these
are the battleground areas
where a win has a critical impact on the
result
trump's victory in 2016 happened because
he won michigan
ohio pennsylvania and wisconsin from the
democrats
joe biden will be attempting to reverse
those losses
while keeping hold of his own heartlands
including nevada
and minnesota well americans won't just
be voting for the next president they'll
also be vote
electing new members of the senate and
the house of representatives the two
chambers
that make up the legislative branch of
the u.s government
in the house all 435 seats are
up for election this year the
republicans have some catching up to do
here
after the midterm elections in 2018
which saw the democrats gain
40 seats meanwhile in the senate there
are a hundred seats but only 35 will be
voted on in 2018 the democrats success
in the house came at the expense
of republican victory in the senate
it can take days for every vote to be
counted but it is usually clear
who the winner is by the following
morning if biden wins he won't
immediately replace trump there is a
transition period
before the new president is officially
inaugurated
on the 20th of january